in 2009 I went out to Zambia and I
visited a rural village where there was
no drinking water and I met this little
boy he was 5 years old and he would walk
12 kilometer round trip to collect clean
water and I just I just couldn't believe
that he would walk that far
and after doing some investigation it
was true and I remember as a teenager
vowing to God that if everyone becomes
successful you have all become rich I'm
gonna go back to that village and build
a a water Wow or a borehole
and to be able to provide drinking water
but I only thought boy but the whole
village of 350 people and a few years
later I was financially free in property
and I remember that boy I remembered the
village and I went back and I built a
borehole 110 meters deep and I couldn't
remember the spring water coming up and
all the local children and the village
is running out to drink out of the water
and it gave me a real sense of
fulfillment and significance and
although it been successful in my
property business success was great but
significance was even greater since then
I've been going back and forth once or
twice a year to different African
countries finding the most needy people
that have absolutely nothing and
bringing aids and helping really poverty
in those areas because I believe that
when you are successful in business when
you have money when you're blessed your
best to be a blessing and you have an
obligation and a duty to help people
that are less fortunate than yourself so
I'm extremely excited to now say that we
have the Samuel Leeds Foundation which
is a registered charity I held off
register in this charity for so long
because I didn't want people to donate
to the charity I just wanted to pay for
it myself out of my own business profits
but people have been on my back to the
last few years saying Samuel we've seen
the work that you're doing we've seen
the lives that you change in we want to
help we want to give so that's why we've
now set up with Samuel Leeds Foundation
which is going to focus on four things
firstly is immediate aid for people that
are in need like bringing water to
people that have no clean water second
literally is education I think that when
you
grow in your knowledge and when you
learn about finance and business and
personal development what happens is
that breaks poverty is the key to
prosperity so we're teaching business
all across different parts of Africa
we're teaching budding entrepreneurs
we're teaching kids we're even working
with the government to try and partner
with them to introduce into the school
systems across Uganda at the moment
personal development and business
finance in the mainstream government
schools so that's a really really
important part of the foundation thirdly
is either the unfortunate experience of
having to have immediate emergency
surgery in Uganda in Uganda and in most
African countries there's no NHS so you
have to pay for treatment and there are
so many people that were coming into the
hospital that we're in serious needs
they were worse off than I were but they
didn't have the money to pay for their
operations and they'd just be sent home
so I've partnered again with the lady
who did the surgery on my leg I've
partnered with her and what the
foundation is doing is it's giving money
to people that are in desperate need of
operations and surgery that cannot
afford it and we're going to help work
with those people because I tell you
something nothing worse than being
absolute agony in hospital but not being
able to afford the treatment fourth
thing is most exciting potentially is
we're building schools so right now
we're building a school in Uganda
there's a lot of schools out here in the
villages whereby kids can't go to school
the schools are too far or the local
schools are just the butler building so
we're building schools out here in
Uganda and I want you to do that across
the whole nation of Africa I've no idea
how much this is gonna cost but we'll
figure that out you have an hour later
so if you want to get involved in these
projects then you can now we have this
registered foundation registered charity
it's a couple of ways you can help
firstly is you can give if you want to
give or speak to myself or the team and
we'll give you details of how you can do
that but what I'd probably encourage you
to do what's more powerful than just
giving some money is get financially
free yourself like I did and then come
out here and help out because your time
is more valuable than your money if
you're financially free as a result of
my training and you want to come out to
Africa and you want to help out again
tell me tell the team and we can bring
you out if you've got a burning desire
to come
but you haven't really got much to give
financially I believe that you can't
help the poor by being poor yourself so
get educated become financially free and
then come out from a position of
abundance actually able to give actually
able to help being able to get the time
off work because you're financially free
yourself so my mission in the UK is to
teach people to become financially free
same across Africa
that's the charity Samuel Leeds
foundation and thank you so much for
your support god bless you
[Music]